il était jeune il était beau des
chanteurs en herbe des graines de stars
alors et de leur éclosion et vassal
photographe de presse a su les saisir
dans leur vérité leur simplicité leur
authenticité
je suis très content de pouvoir dans ce
livre montrer ce qu'était à cette
période
ces artistes qui étaient en devenir de
devenir des super stars comment il était
c'est à dire d'une tous à 90%
il était naturel simple sympa le monde
s'est ouvert à moi grâce à edith et tout
le monde suit derrière les bana djer
suivent tous ces gens là viennent et
m'amène des artistes en disant avec
hugues d'abord ça nous plaît ensuite et
al crédit piaf et ensuite il ya on est
sûr qu'il fera la une de france dimanche
et moi je photographiais sans que sans
aucune contrainte ça c'est unique
[Musique]
cet homme extraordinaire qui a été
pionnier des jeux les vécus mais je l'
ai vécu aussi avec cette simplicité
qu'il y avait dans ses amours avec cv
dans ses colères après sylvie dans les
jalousies sylvie à son égard son mariage
il ne serait ce que la naissance de
david il n'était pas là le premier jour
elle deuxième viol il arrive j'ai vu un
gamin c'est un gamin tout petit gamin
tout timide qui a ouvert la porte de la
chambre
rusé y avait c'est sylvie et son fils
j'ai vu le gamin pure en disant c'est
mon fils et ça c'est inoubliable
c'est du vrai johnny dans l'intimité des
stars de la chanson est un livre conçu
écrit à plusieurs mains
hugues vassal a bénéficié de la
complicité de deux journalistes de la
presse locale qui ont su lui donner la
réplique
elisabeth sega avait un super tour d'un
mathieu pays aussi je les avais repéré
et je leur ai demandé de venir me donner
justement d'apporter leurs pattes à ce
que je leur raconte ray avec mes photos
ce qu'ils ont fait avec beaucoup de
talent
le mérite de ce photographe attachant de
4 ans à 6 ans cofondateur de l'agencé
gamma c'est de nous offrir un regard
plein de tendresse sur le temps qui
passe et sur ces artistes qui ont écrit
les plus belles pages de l'histoire de
la variété française
[Musique]